estamos en este momento en la Explanada
que une el distrito financiero de París
a mis espaldas la defensa con la
prefectura de enanteer y estamos también
apenas 50 metros de donde toda esta
tragedia se originó el asesinato del
joven nael a manos o baleado por la
policía sí efectivamente hemos
conversado con varios transeúntes que
han pasado por aquí en este momento en
esta época del año aquí en la Explanada
usualmente hay muchas personas que
vienen a compartir después del trabajo
que vienen a ser picnic etcétera hoy la
situación es diferente hemos conversado
con comerciantes también que cerraron
muy temprano nos dicen que hace dos días
no tienen clientes y la razón de todo
esto es porque temen que va a haber
nuevamente violencia esta noche algunas
chicas que pasaban por aquí nos
comentaban que han hablado con amigas y
familiares en regiones lejos de aquí
sobre todo en el centro de París para
pasar el fin de semana allí y evitar una
nueva noche de disturbios como como
sucedió anoche y antenoche
por supuesto también hay que ubicarlo en
el contexto Porque esa presunción de los
ciudadanos coincide con las
preparaciones del propio gobierno
sabemos que el ministro del interior
anunció la suspensión de todo el
transporte de autobuses Y tranvías a
partir de las nueve de la noche hasta
nuevo aviso hay varias ciudades
colindantes con París en toque de queda
nocturno también hasta el el lunes y
otra serie de medidas por ejemplo como
en la el despliegue de vehículos
blindados de la gendarmería es decir que
el gobierno Espera que la escena sea
realmente bélica de enfrentamientos muy
fuertes en los que van a ocurrir a
partir de esta noche están suspendidos
también todos los eventos públicos en
todo el país la venta de fuegos
artificiales de dispositivos explosivos
de productos inflamables y químicos es
decir que si tenemos en cuenta la
indignación que todavía persiste en
estos barrios populares con la inacción
del gobierno en lo que refiere a la
violencia policial alguna medida
definitiva que calme sus ánimos podemos
Por supuesto inferir que va a vivirse
aquí en París en los en las zonas
aledañas de París y en varias partes del
territorio nacional una nueva noche de
disturbios brutales
precisamente por la muerte del joven
nael Hace unos días aquí en anteajos